we realized that covet 19 could have
serious social economic and political
consequences for this region's it's
critical that we ensure these countries
are well equipped to detect test isolate
and treat cases and identify contacts I
am encouraged to see that this is
occurring in many countries despite
limited resources many countries are
asking people to stay at home and
shutting down population movement which
can help to limit transmission of the
virus but can have unintended
consequences for the poorest and most
vulnerable people
I have called on governments to put in
place social welfare measures to ensure
Venerable people have food and other
life essentials during this crisis in
India for example Prime Minister Modi
has announced a 24 billion US dollars
package including free food rations for
800 million disadvantaged people cash
transfers to 200 for 4 million poor
women and free cooking of gas for 80
million households for the next three
months many developing countries will
struggle to implement social welfare
programs of this nature for those
countries debt relief is essential to
enable them to take care of their people
and avoid economy collapse this is a
call from the WTO the World Bank and IMF
debt relief for developing countries
three months ago we knew almost nothing
about this virus collectively we have
learned an enormous amount and every day
we learn more
de Blasio is committed to serving all
people everywhere with the best evidence
to protect their health
de Blasio develops guidance based on the
totality of evidence collected from
around the world every day our staff
talked to thousands of experts around
the world to collect and disturb the
evidence and experience we constantly
review and update our guidance as we
learn more and we're working to adapt it
for specific contexts for example we
recommend hand washing and physical
distancing but we also recognize this
can be a practical challenge for those
who lack access to clean water or who
live in cramped conditions together with
UNICEF and the International Federation
of the Red Cross we have published new
guidance for improving access to
hand-washing the guidance recommends
that countries set up hand-washing
stations at the entrance to public
buildings offices bus stops and train
stations and many countries are doing it
we're also working hard with researchers
all over the world to generate the
evidence about which medicines are most
effective for treating covett 19:00
there has been an extraordinary response
to our call for countries to join the
solidarity trial which is comparing for
drugs and drug combinations so far 74
countries have either joined the trial
or are in the process of joining out of
this morning more than 200 patients had
been randomly assigned to one of the
study study arms each new patient who
joins the trial gets us one step closer
to knowing which drugs work
we're also continuing to study the
evidence about the use of masks WHS
priority is that frontline health
workers are able to access essential
personal protective equipment including
medical masks and respirators that's why
we're continuing to work with
governments and manufacturers to step up
the production and distribution of
personal protective equipment including
masks there is an ongoing debate about
the use of masks at the community level
whi recommends the use of medical masks
for people who are sick and those caring
for them however in these circumstances
masks are only effective when combined
with other protective measures whu-oh
contain continues to gather all
available evidence and continues to
evaluate the potential use of masks more
broadly to control covered 19
transmission at the community level this
is still a very new virus and we're
learning all the time the pandemic
evolves so does the evidence and so does
our advice but what doesn't change is
WHS commitment to protecting the health
of all people based on the best science
without fear or favor I thank you thank
you very much earlier to Tetris we will
now open the floor for questions I will
just remind you that we will try to keep
one question per person so we try to get
as many as possible as we were late we
will not be able to stay very long so
let's start first from Italy do Leo from
our I do Leo can you hear us
can we try one more time for Italy
deullyeo gianmaria okay we don't have a
dually online we make try to come back
to him let's try to Jamil from Brazilian
media Jamil can you hear us
yes can you hear me Turk
yes Emil please go ahead dr. Jose thank
you for taking my question yesterday
specially president Bose owner has
misused your words to justify his policy
in Brazil my question to you what is
your message to the Brazilian people and
to the Brazilian leadership thank you
I think the message that oho is giving
to to all countries is that we need a
comprehensive strategy to respond to
this disease we need in addition to any
measures around lock down we need to put
in place a comprehensive strategy based
on surveillance on public health
intervention case detection testing
isolation quarantine and strengthening
our health systems to absorb the blow
and the blow that many health systems
around the world have had to bear over
the last number of weeks which has been
a tragedy for all those caught up in us
it's really really important that all
countries take this seriously
get ready prepare their health system
strengthening the public health
architecture engage their communities
educate communities and bring
communities on board and bring and leave
no one behind and I think this is advice
we're giving to all countries not just
Brazil thank you very much doctor and we
will try one more time with Dhulia from
Italy he was he was on mute apparently
Giulio are you available now
Dulli Oh general yeah
can you unmute unmute yourself
apparently it is not working so we will
move on move to Stephanie from Reuters
Stephanie can you hear me thank you yes
can you hear me yes please go ahead
thank you thank you very much perhaps a
question a data question perhaps from
Mike China has some has now disclosed
that it's um you know the number of
asymptomatic cases and that they're not
counting it's in their in their
statistics that they are reporting as
confirmed cases I wondered if you could
comment for that for us please and put
it in some context today for example
they said there were about a hundred and
thirty asymptomatic Lai's cases which
they're excluding how their figures can
help us understand that the South China
Morning Post has said that according to
classified data there's 43,000 cases so
how does that tally as a ratio with you
know 80,000 confirmed cases and and dude
are you getting an accurate reading of
the situation giving you an accurate
picture thank you hi Stephanie yeah good
to hear your voice again I'm going to
pastor Marie on this because Marie has
been been tracking this one thanks
Stephanie so with regards to the
reporting of cases our case definitions
include laboratory confirmed cases
regardless of the development of
symptoms because we know that there are
individuals who are followed up through
contact tracing and they're identified
very quickly and some of those
individuals who are dead who are
identified have not yet developed
symptoms and so it's important for us to
capture those individuals as part of
case detection as part of surveillance
because from data that we've seen from
from China in particular we know that
individuals who are identified who are
listed as asymptomatic about 75% of
those actually go on to develop symptoms
so when we look at our language and we
look
what proportion of the reported cases
are asymptomatic it's important to
classify those as no symptoms and PCR
positive and then do not go on to
develop symptoms those individuals who
are identified as asymptomatic at the
time of reporting and go on to develop
symptoms so 75% of those are actually
pre-symptomatic there in that
pre-symptomatic phase and then of course
most of the people that are identified
are symptomatic and we know that through
transmission the transmission of this
virus is driven by people who are
asymptomatic but it is important for us
to capture that full spectrum of illness
that full spectrum of detection through
surveillance so again our case
definition includes laboratory confirmed
cases regardless of the development of
symptoms thank you very much we will go
to a Michael contributor to CNN Michael
can you hear us I can hear you can you
hear me
yes please go ahead okay thank you for
taking my call I'm dialing in from
British Columbia today in a little
around three weeks from now the holy
month of Ramadan will commence of course
hundreds of millions of faithful will be
partaking in this breaking their fast
eating together sharing food there's the
tradition as you know of Ramadan tents
where large numbers gather I know
director general as a former UNICEF
spokesperson in that region it's very
important to get an ambiguous and clear
public health messaging out early if
behaviors are to be changed in any way
what would be your message right now to
religious leaders to government's in the
region in order to prevent a further
outbreak during this very special time
of the year thank you yeah thank you
thank you so much in this response and
in the fight against this pandemic the
role of political leaders is central the
role of business leaders is very very
important and central to
and the role of religious leaders and
community leaders is very very important
and we're reaching out to government
leaders political leaders business
leaders religious leaders and community
leaders and other influencers it's
through those leaders that we can reach
out to all communities to take part in
in the fight then having having said
this with regard to Ramadan as you have
been following countries in the Middle
East have been doing everything they can
to limit the spread of the virus and we
will continue to engage them and I know
that we will have an amicable solution
on on on this one - we're very close and
closely working and our cooperation so
far is very very successful and we hope
that we'll continue in that spirit by
the way not only something they're doing
for their own region we're getting a lot
of financial support from the Middle
East and from the you know Arab League
members and I would like to use this
opportunity actually to thank them not
only for taking serious measures in
their respective countries but for their
solidarity to support countries who need
support and the recent pledge as you
remember is from Saudi Arabia which I
have said a few days ago and yesterday
from Kuwait a big financial support and
we will keep in touch we will work with
them closely and I know they will
continue to sub to protect their own
people but at the same time support
countries and communities who need
their support thank you very much just
we go to Guatemala now to cassia Ortiz
Diageo dela Olga can you please ask your
question thank you so much can you hear
me yes please thank you
how do you see the situation for Cove
igniting in Central America and what are
your recommendations for the governments
thank you very much yes yeah I think
there's the countries of Central America
are sort of at the at the beginning or
the up SCYTL of of the epidemic there
are different capacities in different
countries and different risks and
different threats there are lots of
vulnerable people migrants and others
who are scattered throughout the the sub
region and there are many other
communities who may be left behind as
well so Central America is dealing with
the challenge and its own challenges
certainly the small island nations of
the Caribbean equally have to have
different challenges so each country has
a different combination of economic
challenge social challenge it's
vulnerable populations it's public
health system its healthcare system and
how all this is put together and it's
really important that each country and I
am glad to report that almost every
country in Central and South America now
has a national action plan that is being
supported by the international community
by in many cases by humanitarian
partners in the in the UN system and NGO
partners and some countries do need that
external assistance it's also important
the countries in the Americas and
Central America and the Caribbean and
South America are coordinating amongst
each other to align their strategies and
to align their policies so we don't see
massive differentials in in inaction and
pushing people from one side to the
other we have people moving throughout
the the Americas and we need to be
sensitive to those who have least and we
need to be sensitive
to those who are most vulnerable but it
is important that Central America like
all sub regions scales up its public
health response scales of its community
engagement scales up its healthcare
preparedness and has as the Director
General has said so many times and all
of government approach to this this is
serious this is a deadly virus people
will get through it countries will get
through it but we must build the
architecture of Public Health the
architecture of our health system if
we're going to get out of an
interminable cycle of economically
punishing lock downs and shutdowns we
must get back to be able to control this
virus live with this virus develop the
vaccines that we need to finally
eradicate this virus so as I said the
message to Central America is very
similar to that to the rest of the world
if I could just add so we we have within
our guidance materials what we've done
is we've in addition to putting out
general guidance around infection
prevention and control and clinical
management we've put out a series of
government documents relating to the
four C's
you know these locations clusters of
cases community transmission so that
there's specific actions associated with
what needs to be done with whatever
transmission scenario you're in but also
to prepare for other scenarios that you
could eventually be in and get your
systems ready and just activate those
systems now we've seen how this virus
behaves in a number of countries and we
need to prepare for that that may happen
in your country so there's some
practical guidance that we have on our
website related to clinical operations
and getting your hospitals ready finding
locations where you can treat mild
patients versus severe patients readying
your workforce so that you can have
people who can identify cases and help
with case case finding and contact
tracing to help find where you can put
court where you can quarantine your
contacts so there's some practical
information that's online
that's there to help you tailor that
approach and what Mike said around this
comprehensive measures to get yourselves
ready and activate those systems now
thank you very much we will try now to
connect to mr. Bouie agra vidya from
Gazette - net that's Kosovo based outlet
mr. boo yog can you hear us
can you yes please go ahead thank you
from February first until today over
20,000 people have entered Kosovo from
abroad may Italy Germany ins with the
law the first case was confirmed on
March 9 we are now in the fourth week of
the epidemic with one 112 cases in one
thousand and three hundred have been
tested what is the best recommendation
for Kosovo considering these numbers do
you recommend that thing so much
okay Kosmos is a country that has
obviously emerged from very difficult
time has had to rebuild itself service
and to follow to everybody in Kosovo I
spent many months in Kosovo helping to
stabilize the health system in the
aftermath of the great difficulties
there and I know and deeply the
vulnerabilities and the challenges the
health system in Kosovo and the people
of Kosovo have faced over the years and
the health system in Kosovo is still
vulnerable it has many excellent
professionals within assesses hugely
committed workforce but we do need to
ensure that we have in place good
surveillance Kosmos had and built an
early warning system that syndromic it
needs to build on this cosmo needs to
have an active system of detecting cases
we need to have the testing in place and
we need to invest in building the
community's response and having
community-based surveillance and and
strengthening the health care system so
that you can deal with infected cases a
Albania and Kosovo are only across the
water from Italy you were very very
close to some of the most intense
epidemics in the world right now and it
is really important that health systems
in the Balkans in general but in Casa
will specifically need to be rapidly
strengthened and be able to cope with
this disease as it may accelerate so
again with my warmest greetings to all
my friends in in Kosovo we have more
questions from the Balkans we may back
come back to to them later let's go now
to India do we have someone from India
today and it's hi my name is Ankit Kumar
I reproductive degree yes I keep
specialist as the world is the World
Health Organization when tracking the
developments in India
you comment on the progress made by
India in the first week of lockdown and
how do you assess the result so far
thank you I think it's a little early to
assess the results of the lockdown but I
think we need to step back and assess
the results of the response in general
lockdowns and and and shutdowns are
really just should just be part of an
overall comprehensive strategy and what
we need to be able to do as societies
and with the leadership of on all of
government approaches to be able to
implement a consistent policy for a
period of time and then see where that
takes us and then measure and see what
we need to do next we need to be very
careful not to knee-jerk we need to be
very careful not to be changing policies
every single day because people on the
front line need certainty in their days
people communities need some certainty
so it's really important that we are
very consistent in our communication
with communities and our frontline
workers about what we do and we need to
give clear messages about what we do for
the next week or the next two weeks and
we need to then be clear when we're
going to evaluate the impact of that
period of intervention and then if we
have to change we change and we
communicate that clearly and then we do
it again for another two or three weeks
and then we see how that works and then
we gather the information and we consult
with our frontline workers and then if
we have to adjust a change this is about
adapt adjust implement measure do it
again and you just have to keep doing
that over and over and over again until
you control the disease I would love to
say that there's an easy way to do this
I would love to say that there's a way
out of this without that kind of hard
work but there isn't we have to be
comprehensive we have to measure
everything we do we have to measure it
below the national level and and then if
we have to use lockdown if we have to
use shutdowns we do them as part of an
overall comprehensive strategy I would
say India and as the Director General
has has said in his speech has made
a really huge attempt to to limit the
impact of the shutdowns on the people
who are most at risk and people who are
most vulnerable in India and that's a
great thing to see we see increased in
testing we're seeing an increase in
surveillance and we're seeing an
investment in the healthcare system to
be able to deal with more cases but it
is certainly too early for anyone to
determine the impact of the the shutdown
or lockdown measures on disease
transmission at this point thank you
Mike I mean the health issues are very
important as Mike said I would like to
add the other side as you know this is
the first-ever coronavirus pandemic in
the world meaning there are many
unknowns and whether we do shut downs or
take other measures we have to
understand that we're in a learning
process we have to constantly learn from
our actions and I just based on what we
learn but I would like to again
underline this is the first-ever
coronavirus pandemic and its behavior is
still unknown and that's why we should
always be in a learning mode the other
part is not only the public health
measures during shutdown but it should
be the social and economic factors that
we should consider and what India is
doing as I said in my statement is very
very important during shutdowns
there will be economic consequences on
the country at large but more
importantly individuals who
live on daily subsistence who give their
labor for their daily bread could be
affected the most and that's why India
is taking measures like the 24 billion
US dollars package and not only that
this will cover 800 million individuals
as food ration during the difficult
times and cash transfers to 204 million
woman and of course 80 million
households will also benefit for the
next months from getting free cooking
gas that's the kind of support we said
it should be given so we should not see
it from the public health part alone but
see it from the angle of what the
consequences of these public health
measures will be on the community and
try to support our citizens and this
should be seen during this difficult
times during the lockdowns as so-called
and that's how we can get the best
impact but at the same time cooperation
from our communities - because if we
understand and try to help them but
there was another important element I
mentioned in my pressure today because
it's very important I'll repeat it many
countries many developing countries
cannot really support their social
society especially during lockdown
especially on those community members
who work for their daily breads and
that's why we called on the
international
munity to have a debt relief to support
those countries but as you also know
that relief processes are actually
lengthy but what we're proposing
together with the World Bank and IMF is
an expedited process to support
countries so their economy will not be
getting into crisis and their
communities will not be really getting
into crisis this is a time when we need
solidarity not only for public health
but also to address the economic and
social challenges that many countries
are facing as we speak
I will repeat with what I started this
is a pandemic
for the first time caused by a corona
virus and whose behavior is not really
known and we have to stand in unison to
fight this unknown and dangerous virus
one of the things that we are working
very hard on is to systematically assess
the response actions that are being
taken by countries as dr. Tejas has just
said this is the first pandemic of a
corona virus and it's important for us
to to critically look at what countries
are doing so that we can assess these
and see which actions have worked best
and which combination of these have
worked best and there's a lot of factors
that go into this that relate to this
comprehensive approach that we've been
talking about so for example you know
what are the testing strategies that
countries are using and and what is the
percent positive that they're seeing in
terms of the numbers of tests that
they've done what is their surveillance
strategy how our countries looking for
cases are they looking at suspect cases
and contacts are they trying to identify
additional cases through existing
respiratory disease surveillance systems
like their ili or their sorry
surveillance system
how are the public measures being
applied and when and where what movement
restrictions are put in place when and
where and for how long you know how our
our governments and and leaders
communicating with their populations
with their people what type of support
is being provided to communities and and
how are we innovating and how are we
conducting research to learn and feed
that back into the response all of those
things need to be done at a national
level and at sub-national levels to look
and see which actions are the most
effective
we have evidence from Asia in terms of a
number of countries now that have broken
this down to sub-national levels to look
at what has been done where and what
we've been saying about aggressively
looking for cases testing case suspect
cases finding contacts quarantine in
contacts isolating patients and caring
for them depending on their severity
those work but we also need to
continually assess what is being done as
this pandemic moves across the globe so
that we can we can build up that
evidence base to show what works and to
make sure that countries have a tailored
approach to their response thank you
very much from India we will move to
Scotland Anthony from dick Gowdy Anthony
I can clean hear me yes please go ahead
great so I'm absolutely unknown from
there Gaddy newspaper because of the
pandemic millions of students around the
world have had split the studies on hold
could you elaborate on what the w-h-o
national governments can do to aid
students and educational institutions a
difficult time thank you the first of
all we thank all the medical nursing
physiotherapy and other in educational
institutions around the world who wanted
to find job turning out such wonderful
professionals who can come and help in
the front line in so many countries
clearly we we thank them those
institutions and those individuals who
are stepping for
volunteer but we also have to be sure
that those individuals are protected
that they're doing work that they're
well trained and qualified to do they're
well supervised than that they actually
can assistant and add to the value of
the response so we have a duty of care
to them and the duty of care to the
patients to ensure that we're given the
best possible care and we're using pre
qualified professionals in any part of
the medical system are doing work that
they're capable of doing and supervised
in doing with mm-hmm it's also obviously
very important that we that at some
point that these students particularly
the ones who were near final exams have
the opportunity to qualify and get into
the system and I'm sure that national
medical nursing and other educational
policies are being adjusted and adapted
to see how that can be achieved and I'm
pastor Maria if she has any further
points on this matter but we will
certainly be happy to work with national
governments and with national medical
nursing and other educational institutes
to see if we can come up with rational
policies to guide the completion of
education for many particularly late
stage students in the medical
professions thank you very much to
Russia yes I can hear you can you give
me yes please go ahead yes hi thank you
very much for taking my question here in
Russia we see a sharp rise in the local
wholesale and retail prices of ginger
could you please clarify whether ginger
can really help to prevent or treat the
new corona virus or is it just a myth I
think we have to be careful from what we
would consider to be the traditional
remedies that people use for making
themselves feel better
during a common cold or the flu or any
illness we've all had illnesses and some
of us like to take a drink with honey
some like to take ginger some of us take
special herbal teas anything that makes
one feel better anything that provides
that reassurance and anything that you
believe can help your health that's not
dangerous certainly has a positive
impact on your health but it's a
different thing to say that something is
effective in treating the disease at
this moment there is no therapy that has
been proven to be effective in the
treatment of kovat 19 we've explained in
the DG's explained actually earlier
about the Solidarity trials and many
other trials that are testing many many
different compounds around the world
including the ones that are most
promising so I would advise people that
if you have your favorite remedy that
you use like on here like lemon like
ginger please continue to to support
yourself through the and through the
illness but please let us avoid making
assumptions without evidence that
certain things can cure Koba 19 at the
moment there is no proven therapy for
covert 19 Maria thank you very much 24
now we will go to Karen Wolfe saundh
from a World Health Alert crisis Karen
was with us almost every press
conference so we are happy to hear from
her now Karen please go ahead good
morning and good evening I'd like to ask
how can individuals be leading that
clove in nineteen is a real threat and
what each person does makes a difference
some people still don't understand that
if they fail to follow the physical
distancing rules they could be infecting
other people that may lead us further
down the line or is it the case that
some individuals need to be persuaded
that what's happened
in their community as a whole it's
really important and that's a greater
sense of local community needs to be
established in order for them to take on
physical distancing but that's my
question I think you almost answered the
question in your question in the sense
that Kovan 19 is a real threat it is a
real threat to everyone on the planet
it's a new virus which means everyone is
susceptible to infection it is a virus
that causes disease in people which
range from some individuals will have
mild disease and a large proportion 15%
will have severe disease another 5% will
have critical disease and some people
will die so many individuals who will
develop severe disease are older but we
have seen in a number of countries that
younger people are dying I'm looking at
data from Italy here and we have
individuals in their 30s who are dying
we have individuals in their 40s and
their 50s who are dying this is a virus
that can be very serious in individuals
and so it's a real threat it not only
has public health implications but it
has very strong social and economic
implications and everyone needs to
understand that they have a role to play
every person has a role to play in this
pandemic in a sense of duty to ensure
that they take every precaution that
they can to protect themselves from
getting infected and we've listed a
number of ways in which people can
protect themselves through hand hygiene
and respiratory etiquette through
physical distancing by removing
opportunities for yourself to get
infected if you can prevent yourself
from getting infected you could prevent
onward transmission to someone who may
be more vulnerable who could develop
more severe disease and die and that is
a responsibility that you have to
yourself to protect yourself
to protect your family and protect your
community and your loved ones and that
is something that everybody needs to
understand every person on the planet
has a role to play here and there they
have they need to feel empowered to be
able to do something about that to
protect themselves
thank you very much for that we have a
time relief for one or two more
questions so we will go to Nigeria now
to innocent Annetta from a metro Star
newspapers newspaper in a Nigeria
innocent can you hear us
I can hear you good evening sir please
go ahead we could hear you okay my
question is this we landed about 500 at
Alito in Lagos in Nigeria particularly
and just lockdown in Lagos Abuja and
published each recently the people in
Lagos are filling in a total lockdown
within two days I think no protest what
has table he give in tune in German
government as a guidance to manage the
situation on ground especially now that
we have a lockdown in Lagos Abuja and
Augustine's know we have less
ventilators in this country
thank you the line wasn't the best but
manna standing did the question is how W
choice is helping Nigeria in terms of
medical supplies we've been working very
closely with Nigeria since the beginning
and particularly with the Ministry of
Health and Nigeria CDC in fact the
Director General myself spoke with the
director of Nigeria CDC latest was this
morning with the chick Wei Wei Zoo and
actually we're reviewing our support to
to Nigeria what more we could do we have
been supporting lab Diagnostics we have
been supporting with the creation of
isolation facilities we have actually
been in Nigeria supporting
chick way and his teams and the
in Nigeria Ministry of Health for years
on lassic control on monkey pox control
on cholera control we've we don't come
to Nigeria we don't arrive in Africa and
on the continent we are there we are
there every day of every week of every
year working hand in hand with our
colleagues of Ministry of Health and our
other partners in the UN system we've
been beefing up our support strengthen
our country office and again supporting
on clinical medical and on laboratory
science in fact Nigeria has developed a
very strong public health approach in
the last number of years and first
country in Africa to to establish a full
Center for Disease Control which has
been inaugurated by the government only
last year so yes there are challenges
and there are certainly challenges in
the country as big as Nigeria with the
diversity of climates the diversity of
population the diversity of contexts
from the the the northern Nigeria all
the way through the tropical zones and
South Nigeria southern Nigeria to the
massive cities of Lagos so Chetan there
are challenges but there are great
capacities in Nigeria we will continue
to scale up our support particularly on
laboratory diagnosis and we spoke with
dr. Jick way about that this morning we
will continue to ramp up our support
around medical protective gear and
certainly dr. tikka was very clear I'm
worried what he needed more from WH o
and we are determined to deliver that in
the interests of the people of Nigeria
thank you very much we will go to our
last question for tonight and I will
apologize to all those who wanted to ask
the question but we're not able we are
trying as you can see to to get
questions from as different places as a
different outlets as as possible so last
question we go back here to Switzerland
to log on from RTS log on can you hear
us please yes I can hear you can you
hear me yes please go ahead yes thank
you for taking my question so we've
learned that china is now counting
asymptomatic
cases in this slide how can the public
trust the previous numbers that have
been given by China and if the World
Health Organization agrees that numbers
are important in in this fight against
the pandemic what can be done to keep
countries like China accountable and
transparent lest there can be some
perceptions by the public that the World
Health Organization itself is being
manipulated or taken for a ride in this
crisis thank you I think Maria addressed
the issue of asymptomatic infection
before so I hope you were able to listen
to that answer I want to repeat it you
can certainly listen to the transcript
with regard to the issues of
transparency and working with countries
where we work with with all countries
and in fact if you look at the amount of
data that's been put up by many
countries and if you look at the number
of peer review publications that have
made by colleagues from Korea from Japan
from Singapore from China from other
parts of China like Hong Kong there's
been a deluge of fantastic
scientifically based evidence-based
publications coming out on a daily basis
from college colleagues in all of those
situations there have been I think we
had 27 you were saying this morning very
different teleconferences going on today
with experts all over the world sharing
real-time information with each other
and they all include colleagues from
China and colleagues from Asia so I
think we need to be very careful also to
not to be profiling certain parts of the
world as being uncooperative or non
transparent and we need to look at
transparency across the board we need to
look at solidarity across the board we
need to look at contributions across the
board we need to compare apples with
apples and oranges with oranges we need
to look at the epidemic in Switzerland
as a population-based epidemic and the
population and the the epidemic in in
Italy we need to look at what are
countries and if one country is only
sampling cases over a certain age and
with certain symptoms are they mean
non-transparent or
they preserving maybe a very precious
diagnostic resorts and they don't have
the capacity to test
so sometimes we attribute lack of
transparency to what our natural
limitations in a response our natural
limitations and the lack of availability
of information are we saying maybe that
the lack of precise information from
Italy and the condition of patience is
because of lack of transparency or
because we have a system overwhelmed
with thousands of patients coming in
today every day and doctors and nurses
struggling just to provide basic care
are we saying they're lacking and
transparency and not sending wh all the
data every day no we need to look at the
context here and I think we need to show
a little bit more balance we need to be
critical and we will be and we will work
with every single country to ensure that
we're getting the best possible data
from them but at the same time we need
to be balanced in that and we need to
recognize that systems under pressure
find it hard to share everything on a
minute-to-minute basis and hoping to
strengthen - my response but frankly at
times I think we get over focused on
this issue something that in this era of
this new virus there's there's so many
unknowns there's so many questions that
we have which have been identified
through our research and development
meeting that we had in February but
there are a lot of questions that we
still have and all of these
teleconferences that we're having people
are sharing their experiences with with
not only w-h-o but sharing their
experiences with other countries and as
an evidence-based organization we we
rely on that data we rely on that
evidence and in countries that are
overwhelmed right now they may not be
able as Mike just said they may not be
able to capture that and report that and
conduct those studies that need to be
done but other countries that aren't as
overwhelmed or that have higher levels
of capacity there's certain research
that can be done right now that could
answer critical questions around virus
shedding around modes of transmission
around many different things Natural
History and so it's almost like a call
to action here in this solidarity that
we have for this virus to try to better
capture the data and the results from
studies where we can so that I could
feed and it can help other countries
that may be overwhelmed at the present
time so we are seeing that we are seeing
countries that are doing studies that
are sharing results and we hope that
that will continue we know that that
will continue and we're very happy to to
collaborate with an with a number large
number of groups regularly through
teleconferences and reading those papers
I have to say it's even hard for us to
keep up with the papers but we have
large numbers of teams that are going
through those publications and we thank
groups that are sharing their
publications pre-publication materials
with us because it's all reviewed and
it's all fit into our evidence we would
like to add to that I earlier said this
is the first ever pandemic caused by a
corona virus but to that I will also add
it's a new virus too so two things here
one it's a new virus and second it's the
first-ever pandemic by a corona virus
two unknown two new things a meaning
there are many unknowns and that's why
some of the things we didn't know may
come today as as known including the
symptomatic cases that you you said so
let's you know accept things with open
open mind and trust what's coming but of
course at the same time ready to verify
to maybe I could just give a specific
example because I've been sitting here
all afternoon poring over data with
Maria and we were just looking at some
of the viral shedding studies that are
going on all over the world and the
information that's been provided we have
information on viral shedding study in
Germany one Singapore one the United
States one and China four that's what I
was looking at this afternoon we thank
all of those countries for sharing that
early data with us on viral shedding
because this is helping us form policies
on everything from the use of masks to
the length of infection
any of the other risk factors with this
disease we thank all countries who are
sharing this preliminary early
information with us but we also
understand that some countries are in
the middle of the fight of their lives
and they can't necessarily collect this
data at this moment in time and to add
to that actually we agree with many axe
experts were saying that there is better
global cooperation now than previously
because of the experience we had some
you know epidemics and pandemics that
rate can have a big ward
so I think we should continue in that
direction better global cooperation is
is needed that what we are saying but
it's not enough we need to continue to
really do do more in terms of
cooperation but where we are at a better
stage now in terms of cooperation thank
you very much chatting this was very
important message to give to the world
we will conclude here audio file will be
available very soon transcript as always
probably sometimes tomorrow tonight we
will send you a number of links of the
documents produced by our regional or
country offices that give some more
detail about work the WTO is doing in in
different parts of the world there will
be also advisories for press conferences
of our regional offices so please have a
look at that I will wish you a very
pleasant evening or day to everyone and
the Uniting to the three of us on Friday
there will be a special guests surprise
so see you on Friday
see you Freddy